ううっうぅうう do
どうもみなさんこんにちは
吉川と申します私はのここから近いところにある
立正大学の学長をやっております
うはそういう関係で今日の集まり浜
皆さんご存知の子たんのバレエ
一つのキーワードんだと思っていますがそれではお招きいただきました
私はあの専門は経済学です
今日これから様々がライブリーなぁ
のお話があるんだろうと思います
パッと拝見しまして
私はご覧に当院別ですが
ずいぶん若い方が多いなともと私あの大学で済んだよ普段の若い人に
が生まれているんですが
醍醐か若い人がたくさんいるんですけれども大学の外でも集まりば
私がフラン参加する様々な
つまり今日午前中もあるところだの会議とかそういうところではしっかりとか高齢化を
反映しているような
多いんですがまぁ今日こうやって
拝見すると非常に若いカラーと思いなとってそうしたところで
話を少々せて頂け下がりだと思っています
具体的な様々なさきほども言いました
ライブな話というのは後でたくさんあると思うんですが
私は経済学者の立場から一つは特に若い皆さん
こんなことをわれわれは考えているんだけれども
どうですかという話をさせて頂ければと思ってますが
どうでしょうにまあここにんお若い方々というのが特に先ほど会を話している通り
ペイ
私が接するような
学生それから若いサラリーマン
将来の日本特に具体的には自分たちの生活というの親世代
あるいは私はまあまあ純子荒らしてるまぁ段階のは理解
団塊世代と比べて
道
貧しくなるんじゃないかと
樹林なんじゃないかと
日本するたりするんじゃないか
まぁなんとはこういうイメージを持っている人も非常に多い
思います
もちろんいう高さとは何かというのはひょっとしたら今日この集まりたもちょうど
テープの話があるのかもしれませんがちょっとそれを御書にウッドですね
今ここでは常識的に
一人当たりの所得とかのそういうもので
考える
ということにするとですね
皆さんの世代彫刻人が者の皆さんの世代が段階より貧しくなることはありえないと
皆さん方のどれくらいカッコ付き豊かに何かと
いうことを指摘させていただきたいと思います
日本が10人なんじゃないか
日本はどんどん求めてるんじゃないかと
そういう話がまったくていうだとは私も思ってません
あの
まあ投げが一番それを象徴するかやっぱり人口でしょうね
これはもうここにいらっしゃる皆さん目をご存知でしょ
巡行が減っていく
いうのは大変深刻な問題だと私も思っています
今日本の人口っての1億2000万人くらいそれもう全然ご存じないんじゃない
でしょうか
国の方で厚労省ですが社会風習人口問題研究所いくんですが将来人口推計というのを5
年ごとに転がしながらおよそ100年
ぐらい先までの
人口推計をやっています
今
2105年でよかったから多分それくらいまで飲んでたいと思いますジョブない感じ
ちょっと後でホームページ法令100年後
で百年後ですから当然頃館の出生率死亡率に依存してまいります
水系当たるんですよね
で何らかの想定を置くということでと件はないので出生率も運ですけれども
行為注意てい
3つの想定おいて100年後くらいまで数字を出している
皆さんに撮っカレー
振動があるやネット上でのご覧になったことあるんじゃないですか
よく丸括弧中に中位推計とか
変えたりもあるんですよ中学んですっ
まあどういう真ん中を取ってるです常識的
出生率についてね
勝率に同じですがです
さてその今出てる直近の推定でおおよそ100年後
つまり22世紀でですか
22世紀の頭の日本の人口というのは約5000万人になる
いうふうに酔拳者でています
ちなみにということで時計の針を100年戻しますと
まあ1920年ですか
ね大正9年
超る100円もあるとっ
大小の始め頃の日本の人口とも約5000万人になった
つまり100年前の日本の人口との5000万くらいだったのは確認をかけて
1億2000万7000万増えたんですかね
100年かけて7000万円って5000万人あって
もちろん黒蒼天の中には戦争も
非常にシリアスの疫病も
そういうような装丁入っていません
メディアは平和裏にということですが
1億2000万人の順工学部前まで行ってくっていうのは
異常なんじゃないですかね
皆さん年末ですか
女にされた方もあるかも知れませ
昨年2019年の生まれた安倍ちゃんの
勝つんだ背に板
100問いったみたいな
はなしー
そういうのがありましたよね
団塊の世代雲られるの頃は200万近くで
東京なんかはなく種東京ですが表学校
乳清でやってたら痛くない
そういうようなところも
まだだった
ことですがそれはそれとして
繰り返しになりますね1億2000万の5000万人まで行くと
いうのはこのもらい問題ですよ
郵送真夜中の言われて
それ自体否定しようと思うんですけどまぁその話は今日はちょっと秋にもいた上で
さて多くの人はですね
人口が出るもそれにつれて働きても決定か皆さんのような元気静大どんどん入っていく
働き手ないって組んだから経済っていうのは珍楽んじゃないかと
です
それが普通じゃないかと
働く人の数が減って国経済のサイドフェルってのはなんか手順を見た上で
それはちょっと騙されたうん
変な楽観論じゃないかと思っている人も多いみたいなんです
そこがまったく違うというお話をしたいと思います
で普通の方あるいは多くの人が一体に感じるっていうのは頭の中にイメージがある
つまり1人1本ずつしゃべりを持って仕事行って100人で行っている
それがしばらく経っている人工働きて得た80人でなった
できる仕事は減らさざるを得ないだろう
道路工事課の方が社会をやっているか
100人80になった空減るでしょう
一人一人がドーラだか歯食いしばって頑張っても
せいぜい前と同じくらい前と同じっとなチャネルゼロ成長ってです
えっ
そうじゃないかましてに考えればマイナス成長じゃないかと
こういうふうにかそういうイメージじゃないかと
そのイメージが実は先進国民経済ということからすると全く違うということです
1多分な限りご紹介しているどういうことかっ
具体的な社会本売れているんですよ
シャベルで道路工事やってたところに封筒山のべく
100人でやってたのが5人で住むようになると思う
これが先進国の経済成長と
こういうことです
小論 by 話があるのか
ちょっと考えていただけばいくらでもあるんですよ身の回りに
例えば皆さんも若いんだよ
自分が生まれ
育った物心がついた時は全部へ昨日は自動改札だったとまあそういう方々及びを感じ目
してますが
ある程度以上の年齢の方あるいは若い方でも同ご苦労のことあるいは話としては分かる
でしょ
30年くらい前まだですね東京駅でも新宿でも改札全部友人で人をやってたんです
人がこうやって切符を集めたと思う
シャンテイキンの順番にんこういう会社を継ぐ違う
いるという
ということだ基本全部機会にかあっ
そういうことですよね
あるいはたった今の話まさに我々のいるこの後旦那界隈でも今人手不足ということに
なってきましたがま3時から飲食店のような所ではどんどんどんどん
機械化策が進んでいる
いうことをこれはご存知なんじゃないでしょうか具体的な皿を洗う
左手も食洗機でしょうシャロンどんどん
民主県連も帰ってきたッ
こういう話した
あるいはついこの間年末ですかねという風に見てましたら
加工野球を作る機械
くれません
楽焼も3日街頭ででひっくり返したりとか
大変のようですけれどもば階級全部機械でやっちゃう
いうのが開始されたあっ
っていうのをテレビでやってました人間の経済の歴史とも振り返ってみますと
実は人手不足の歴史でもあるんですよ
昔はすべて純力でやってたそれがすべて機会に変わっていくというそういう歴史でも
あったっぷ
そういうことです
斜度問題がそのインパクトということなんですね
さきほども言いましたけれども人口のイメージっての批判注意
人が減っていくんだ
逆にしますけれども行動成長きっ
まぁもう少し濃いくらっちゃいましたなぁ
always 三丁目の夕日と
今やなりました最近でも高度成長の頃
前の東京オリンピックのころも
話とよくテレビなんか話題なん
皆さんご存知だと思うんですね
年々日本経済とな10%で成長しました
当時毎年キューブリヤ
当時の
人口はどうだったかという
答えは1%です
ひょっとしたら皆さんの中には
東寺講堂成長の頃上野駅に集団就職やなのか
若い中学出てきたじょわーっ高
上野駅で
就職集団就職の列車に乗って
集まってくれるぞとの昔の乳清なんかの演奏で白黒の木も
ご覧になった方はなかったんです
あれは国内で移動してるだけですからね
日本全体での人口増っていうのはプライパーセントぐらいな
人口の像は1
経済は年々中
10-1-9は何かといえば一人当たりの gdp 1人当たりの所得が毎年9%伸び
ただ
お隣の中国は
今ニューノーマルと言って成長率ダグ落ちてきています少し前まで10%成長してい
ました
この偶然ですが10%成長を続けてた中国もでも準構造が
時ってパーセン
11球は日本との行動成長期と全く同じ
1人あたりの
所得が伸びて立っ
こういうことですいいタイプでは何か
いうとですね
人口が減るというのは経済のサイズに対しては-2
九州ですこれ間違ってないん
しかしそれで全てが決まるというんではなくて
むしろ一人あたりの
ゲイ db
一人当たりの所得の伸びのところのほうが米量的には大きいとかあ
じゃあする一人当たりの gdp 1人当たりの所得は
どうやってられるか
ちょっと暗くなっちゃってますがそこの壁に後でご覧になれば
コラボレーション選んでイノベーション
まあキーワードが書いてありましたん
まあもう皆さんならご存知でしょうこの
今日も集まりでもキーワードになるかと思います
イノベーション
結局はそういうこと
であるわけです
それはちょっと考えると手順みたいに思うかもしれませんが
まさにその手品みたいなこと親なら2年の経済というのは
出発してきたと
黄銅製超級日本だと繰り返しになりますが人口増のところは年々プラ1
9%急は一人当たりの gdp が伸びるということ
これによって達成されてたっ
それは結局のところへイノベーション
いうことであっ
いうわけです
で最後に目の子山です
日本の人口というのは
だいたい-0どのパーセントくらいのお金がやっていくと端が切れない
人工綿服
細かいことはちっとは切り抜きます
我々の豊かさっというものを決めるのはまあ一人当たりの gdp
jdp の際そのものも
そういうこと言うなっ
1人あたりの g 0です
先ほどから言っている通り gdp そのものはイノベーションでの下のビルト
いうことです
そこで今目の午前として gdp が一転5%ずつ伸びていくという風に考えてみ
ましょう
人口はマイナス0.6%減ってきます
人口が減るって言うことはラントのしょぼい感じがしますが
一人当たりの gdp 所属から言えば雨用意
どんどん減っていくんですから同じ牌を3人で分けるや2人であげるほうがひとり子が
大きくなった
これだけです
gdp が
1.4%伸びていく
人口は0.6%減っていく一人当たりの gdp
2%伸びていく
35年で倍になるんですよ
ということは今ここにいらっしゃる方も所得1人当たりの生涯所得が確実に団塊世代の
生涯所得の倍以上になると
いうことです
これは無責任なから元気ではなかっ
ほとんど算術的な必然性だと
思います
まあそれを実現するためにはキーワードはイノベーションです
そのまま今日のファイルのでもあったりと
考えていますどうも時間少し紹介しました
どうご静聴ありがとうございました